[Music]
in bully beatdown news food I love that
show I miss it a little bring it back
the show yep yeah Jason mayhem Miller
what do you tell me the it's an MMA
fighter with a bully and then go [ __ ]
hit the head and they bite things I
really like when they can the the
bullies actually think they can take
them this I saw this one with the
bodybuilder guy he got [ __ ] on Eddie
Alvarez was it now Eddie Alvarez and
Eddie Alvarez all those guys what the
[ __ ] dude Karl's not anything to do with
fighting anymore Eddie Alvarez like
early 2007 TV right it was mid - thought
you talked yeah it was pretty back in
the day yeah it was far I love that show
especially like the guys that know a
little bit of kickboxing or something
and then it's like dude you're up
against the pro man yeah
imagine if he turns out to be so good
they're like we should probably offer
you a contract instead I want to see one
like that I haven't seen it like that it
weren't just like regular Parrilla UFC
pros they were like really thick shield
Eddie Alvarez they're like the top guys
cool should there be a part of yeah oh
yeah like you mentioned big it you have
like Bart Joe hey we want you to be in a
show where you beat up old school
bullies like I think you guys would love
it so much no I'm not I would like to
send me a way to go train for three
months I could come back and kill
someone cause right now I can't be any
more trainer yeah okay like maybe like
elementary school bullies I like that
you like really think so highly of my
I'm super down on Simone kids she's the
best friend to both of us if I wasn't
even involved
he's like better than me Gina this [ __ ]
over here she's like your best friend
I'm still right here hurry
it's the cameras where'd you come from
I'm one of the guys haven't you seen as
a histogram Davis been boxing there's
been trying to aesthetic ass videos and
your instagrams David yeah tell you
something bout those videos no it took a
long time to make this [ __ ] with like
three different apps I was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I like the way it looks I
don't think you put that much work into
yours
well actually I take that back here mine
I [ __ ] know how much porky yeah come
on now yeah he beat you at your own game
or everything I do like I like into the
story because doing down more yeah I
like it's the story because it's just um
it's like vlogging with no pressure
yeah you know what I mean I somehow turn
my into Tory it's the story it does
something very difficult you know it's
just how I am as a person
all right uh and bully be done he was
submitted by Gina's Twitter father a
father a father was arrested after he
beat up an eighth-grade girl in
retaliation for bullying his daughters
I mean but like is this like is this
girl I guess Samoan she's pretty big
[Music]
great boy or girl a no dad should be
beaten up at 8 remember those girls we
saw in Hawaii in the supermarket they
were big our fans that Foodland owe to
you if you're watching oh you were
taller than me if you're Polynesia I
think it's a fair fight what's a fight
for five enemies adult no adult
adults know better than to fight they
use their yeah I mean I like but like I
like the reason why but he shouldn't
have done it
I'll put it to you like this the guy
that trains me now he like he does to do
competitions he said that there's this
guy that this kid that won so many like
you just you like competitions a few
sixteen because this kid he said that
kid's been training since he was like
five or some [ __ ] yeah I mean so it's
like it within his like family or
whatever I don't know but that's pretty
crazy though a 600 club [ __ ] older guy
sure that when you live when you're
super young my stunts your height height
gross no okay that's [ __ ] boys in
school lied to me man you guys are just
[ __ ] short it's where they got their
information from - yeah cuz I used to
think that - probably got from the Asian
grandpa who knows nothing about living
what about coffee he does it's not your
girl that I don't know everything is
like a thing I don't know what does your
body at a young age there's dad his name
is John 32 years old he was charged with
injury to a child when he got physical
with his daughter's bully so they were
John went was with his wife and they
went to the school to talk to the vice
principal and in the middle of them
talking he told them that he parked his
car in a fire lane and they can needed
to move it so when he went to go repart
his car that's when he saw the bully
girl and he went to the bathroom and he
brought a slammed her head against the
bathroom wall Oh to the point where like
she got like a bump on the back of her
head and so she went I got yeah until
she went to the nurse's office
she needs to [ __ ] up her parents yeah
that's that's right mmm yeah I wouldn't
[ __ ] up a kid that's like that's like if
there was a bad dog in a bad dog bit my
dog I'm not [ __ ] up the dog maybe if
it doesn't let go it's like a llama [ __ ]
up that that owner too when there was
when you're out and there's like this
girl mouthing off to you she's not in
danger it's her boyfriend that's in
danger so like the more you talk the
more all these people here are gonna
[ __ ] your boyfriend up so yeah before
the before the whole vice principal
office thing he was he got into a verbal
altercation with the bully in the
hallway that's when police had it [ __ ]
like the campus police came and
separated them but then he went and got
he found her in the bathroom some people
don't understand oh oh geez oh I was
thinking like a all-american yes I was
thinking to fart again tied around his
[ __ ] you know like a mr. Rogers dad
[ __ ] up my children when you see a
cholo your life he's got a represent
because he couldn't he changed his ways
when he had a kid but it came out
there's like you're not [ __ ] on my
daughter show me a video no that's it
that's it oh damn it there's no video I
tell you I like the intent but maybe not
like you you shouldn't attack a child if
it wasn't illegal am i doing do you
think it'd be cool the other way around
so let's say a mom goes into the boys
bathroom and [ __ ] up the boys bully a
hundred percent i jus said no two adult
fighting children the kid too even if
you bullied even more cuz I ha how your
mom is fighting you're fighting yeah the
mom go the [ __ ] huh your mom yeah keep
on talking my mom's right there yeah
scary moms maybe like not beat him up
maybe just backhand them a little bit
like I think it all depends if you have
a four foot two asian mom no chuckling
do it [ __ ] them up cuz I wouldn't mind
beating up a kid
okay maybe not beat up spank the [ __ ]
out of them yeah but if you're like you
know six five in like 200 you know like
you
bill you shouldn't it's too much power
okay what if your dad is like six foot
four buffest [ __ ] and he goes into the
school he doesn't beat up the kid
because I can't come here lay over my
lap right now and you spank them in
front of everyone
that's not beating up the kid right but
you're still there everything okay
physical contact but your baking is not
beating like it that's different than
slamming her face into a little trouble
for spanking we should maybe we
shouldn't get in trouble for a spanking
other people's kids I yell at other
people's kids in every school there
should be like a boxing ring or a cage
and you know I think I just like the
Mafia method better weights like you've
just done some crazy ass [ __ ] so you
have that reputation so all you gotta do
is you go to mystical hey come here let
me talk to you and then you just tell
them a couple census sentences and then
that kid just turns [ __ ] white that's
too intimidating
I've had done some crazier [ __ ] to
adults don't you do I speak through
someone's eye and then you come to
school and say this isn't a fisheye
because it was like certain kids in
school that were untouchable because not
because they were tough is because okay
you were cool connect how connected they
were I [ __ ] hated those kids cuz they
could say whatever they wanted and they
would like take other people's lunch
money as [ __ ] but you would I would
discipline my own so that they also have
respect yeah yeah I want to be fair my
dad you see you that in school he would
go to school and just pull out like the
biggest or most popular guy and he'd
always go to his side and whisper
something and they never told me what he
said but I think that's what it was what
if it was something nice like hey see
that girl right there that's my daughter
it would mean the world to me if you
just you slip some watch her back yeah
some like that but then if I said like
one kid what's like one kid I asked
what'd he say he says start peeing in
his pants nothing I'm like no really
what do you say they just would not tell
me till they say so don't know what he's
saying probably said some really weird
elem I will I will
open mouth kissing
open-mouth kiss can you imagine oh you
know how I'd look he goes I will open
mouth kiss you and speak Vietnamese at
the same time you know I will sing every
song from Paris by a private one-on-one
performance and even kids either like I
will turn up the reverb in the karaoke
machine I will tongue you and keep my
eyes open the whole time when he was in
the plane in the playground he was
really little and I would see little
[ __ ] kids like being little [ __ ] bags
I'm like [ __ ] how do I handle this
situation I'm nervous about what do you
do I go in and I say hey you don't do
that don't do that and I hope to god the
[ __ ] moms around comes like yeah
you're [ __ ] animal put them on a
level headed I would just removing Isaac
from a situation I'm like I don't want
to talk to other people's kids like I
don't know whose parent this is and like
some of these kids their parent would be
like waiver thought oh my god I wouldn't
be watching the kids yeah I've done that
before like whose there's ways to like
like
punish kids without people knowing like
simply like exam rights and that's a
good one too there's also this thing too
where you have them all play football
and you're the quarterback and you just
chuck it [ __ ] hard at the kid hey
Jimmy ready oh but he gets hit in the
face there's a lot of things I learned
at church I love how you're learning how
to abuse children at church you know
what I learned in school which is dope
you could shake the [ __ ] out of someone
what the fork and a hurts like crazy but
leaves no marks like what he's about Oh
classic no like a metal fork right if I
got a metal
shaking the [ __ ] hurts like what I mean
like you hold it up and you shake it and
you start stabbing them it hurts like
crazy like stab but sh8 and K beef shank
are you sure doesn't make it isn't all
we've done it so many times
yeah we done it so many times all these
kids I just like yelling other people
you know kid the same kids at the school
we used to run that [ __ ] Bulls out step
out of line and they're [ __ ] sell it
ecstasy we're on it I would just watch
the basketball we had a we were we were
in a store with tofu the dog and then
[ __ ] that person and this lady she
had like her son who so doesn't want
those [ __ ] kids I ran over did tofu
and tried to grab her a tail and I was
like hey and like I had to show my boy
cuz tofu hates when people come up to
her and if she bites him then that's her
fault like they're not like someone
grabbed the dogs he's [ __ ] stupid it's
your old kid those dumb and I yell at
the moms like hey you need to come get
your kid he's trying to grab the dog she
goes again and then she just comes over
and grabs her kid I'm like you a
football on you let's play exactly play
football miss be anything play baseball
but don't give him a bat oh it's great
I'm just gonna carry football everywhere
I go now yeah the self defense football
[Music]